hey y'all movie retrospective time again
doing a horror comedy musical yeah this
time
uh this actually won by a landslide i
don't know who's the landslide but it
won by a very significant margin in the
uh patreon poll it's weird because i
love this movie but i hadn't actually
thought about doing a review of it until
a couple of people i guess on one of our
previous shows like in the chat just got
to talking about it was like oh you guys
should review it so i put it in the poll
in the last minute and it won so this is
uh the 1986 version of little shop of
horrors it's hard to believe that this
was 86
it really is just goes to show you how
much practical effects have declined
over the years
i mean
this was a long time ago
and that damn plant looks like it's
alive i mean it looks like a real
character and people are like
interacting with it it doesn't look real
but it does look alive it looks like an
alien plant yeah and i kind of i kind of
want to get into like how they did all
the stuff with that plant because i had
i mean i watched this movie probably
like a million times like in the late
80s i had the soundtrack on cassette
i think i had it on video like i taped
it off cable or whatever and it looked
awesome back then but i probably hadn't
watched it for like 20 years or
something so when we were watching it
again for this review i was like i
cannot [ __ ] believe how amazing that
[ __ ] planet looks yeah and it's all
it's all puppetry and like animatronics
and stuff
well it's also the whole movie the color
filters and everything it's a real
colorful movie
it's obviously supposed to be
something that you're seeing on a
broadway play yeah because that's
musical yeah and it's it's not supposed
to be realism it's just
entertainment and it's an all-star cast
and everybody in it just hits it out of
the park
it's real close to kind of like a horror
version of greece i say it's as good as
greece oh easily even though i kind of
like grease a little better i think it's
a little more nostalgic for me i like
the music a little bit better in greece
but not by much it's like it's like
greece with uh travolta and olivia
newton john's it's like that i mean it's
that good
i mean i kind of feel like little shop
of horrors again this is another movie
from the 80s where i couldn't find a
single negative review of it
everybody that's seen this movie loves
how can you not love this [ __ ] movie
it's just so lovable you know
it's got steve martin in it being a uh
basically like a a 50s rocker kind of
elvis but he's a motorcycle motorcycle
guy with his [ __ ] bondage boots and
[ __ ] and he's like a sadistic [ __ ]
dentist
singing like elvis is [ __ ] great you
know and then his girlfriend
she's a beautician no she worked at the
nightclub no she works at the flower she
works at the flower shop yeah with uh
with scenes it looked like a damn
beautician's outfit that she had on she
said she worked in a nightclub like at
nights that was like her side yeah she's
like this kind of new york kind of dig
bat who's real hot [ __ ] fantastic
boobs
rick moranis is in it playing kind of
like this beta loser who ends up being
kind of like the hero you know who finds
a damn alien plant
and it's just a lot a lot of cool people
in there [ __ ] uh jim blue she's in it
just
everybody it's all-star cast yeah i mean
christopher guest is in it john candy's
in it like cameos bill murray is in it
like in a cameo that's right it's just
yeah it's just this is one of those
things that just came together
and everything was just like perfection
you know it's like everything about this
is cool like the [ __ ] the look of it
is cool everybody in it is cool all the
songs are good it's just the premise of
it is hilarious because i love [ __ ]
uh you know dark comedies like this
um so
in case you guys don't know because i
don't know some people maybe that are
younger and stuff
don't know but this movie has a really
fascinating uh backstory of uh history
so back in 1960
good old roger corman uh you know king
of the bees as they used to call him he
made a little movie uh called little
shop of horrors he made this movie
reportedly in two days uh on sets that
he had previously used for a bucket of
blood yeah i but the story goes i don't
know if it's true or not the story goes
that somebody bet him that he couldn't
make a movie in two days and he was like
hold my beer and he did uh apparently
the original little shop of horrors
which was not a musical uh cost about
thirty thousand dollars to make
and it in it he came up with essentially
the same premise where's the there's a
nerdy guy that works at a flower shop
he's a horticulturist he ends up
actually in the original movie which i
actually have watched
um he does the plant is not an alien
it's just a hybrid that he came up with
uh but it's the same story the plant
talks uh the plant eats people and he
ends up having to
you know accidentally on purpose murder
people to feed to the plant uh because
the plant is growing bigger and bigger
and it's like making the store famous
and it's like making them a lot of money
so it kind of goes on like that fun fact
in the 1986 version uh you know the si
the masochistic dennis patient that's
played by uh bill murray in the original
movie that part was played by a very
very young jack nicholson oh that'd be
cool and it is like super super funny i
actually had i think i saw the original
movie like a long time ago but i wanted
to rewatch it like before we did this
review and that movie
is [ __ ]
funny i didn't like realize how [ __ ]
funny a movie from 1960 could be but
holy crap that movie is hilarious yeah
that scene in this movie is also really
cool i hadn't seen it in a long time i
didn't realize how much it was basically
a homosexual bondage scene
it is [ __ ] hilarious it's uh
just you know bill murray trying to be a
gay sub who's just totally into the pain
and [ __ ] murray being the sadistic
[ __ ] alpha who's like a pissed that
he's enjoying it
really
really if if you're if if you're
somebody that some chick or some dude
that has a crush on [ __ ] steve martin
this is definitely his sexiest role it
is
he's [ __ ] looking good he's probably
about 40. he's in real good shape he's
got [ __ ] motorcycle bondage pants on
and 60s retro
[ __ ] rocker motorcycle boots with the
damn buckles that go all the way down
and then his dennis [ __ ] white dennis
top on there with his [ __ ] elvis
haircut and [ __ ] and [ __ ] he's just
really hamming it up he's kind of very
much like lux interior
that's kind of yeah i was kind of
getting luck's interior i was kind of
getting out
he's kind of like punk rocker and
bondage and elvis all kind of
with his with a with a fairly distant
fairly decent mississippi accent fairly
decent and i have to say i mean as much
all the songs in this are good but i
mean dentist is the song that i kind of
feel like everybody remembers yeah even
though it's nothing to do with the plant
um and the plant is amazing too but i
kind of feel like steve martin and bill
murray came in with that sequence where
he sings dennis and it's just almost
like he steals the movie now this is
happening either in the early 60s or the
50s so yeah it's a period piece it's set
in the early 60s because that's when the
original movie yeah you know was made
that kind of adds to the fetishness of
it it looks like cheesecake art the
whole [ __ ] thing you expect betty
page to show up sometimes but it's a
movie like that yeah
so what ended up happening so like i
said this roger corman movie which was
like just this cheap knockoff flick that
you know it was just like the the bottom
of a double bill yeah with uh i think it
was black sunday like the mario obama
movie and uh so they made that and then
for whatever reason uh in the early
1980s uh david geffen and like some
other people wanted to make an
off-broadway version of it
so um
alan menken and howard ashman who would
later go on to do like a bunch of music
for like some of the disney animated
like aladdin and beauty and the beast
and stuff uh so they worked on a lot of
the songs for the off-broadway version
and david geffen then was kind of like
okay well now we want to make like a big
screen version because he thought it
would be like this really
you know he thought it'd be really
successful so they have the songwriters
in there uh originally when they were
first working on this uh the movie
version was supposed to be and this
would have been super weird i think the
movie version was supposed to be
directed by martin scorsese
and produced by steven spielberg
uh but what ended up happening was that
there was a that would have been great
it might have been i mean it probably
been like this though it has that tone
already
yeah although i don't know i kind of
feel like it maybe wouldn't have been
the same but i don't know how to soften
it up some
yeah and i kind of want to get into that
too because uh there's something about
like an alternate ending and i kind of
want to talk about that because that's
kind of like a big deal
but um but yeah so there were like a
bunch of delays because the screenwriter
from the original movie was like you
know threatening to sue for this that
and the other so they didn't really get
to it and then like martin scorsese and
steven spielberg bowed out uh john
landis was kind of interested in
watching which also might have been
entertaining because you know he's
pretty awesome
but then he kind of didn't do it either
so they ended up giving it to frank oz
now obviously if you know anything about
anything frank oz uh best known in his
early days as a puppeteer obviously he
did a lot of muppets he did yoda uh he'd
miss piggy fozzie bear
he does you know all the soup grover for
sesame street and he was starting to
parlay like his puppetry and stuff into
directing so prior to doing this movie
he had just done the muppets take
manhattan which
is probably my favorite muppet movie i
mean they're all good but i think
muppets take manhattan is my favorite so
um as soon as he was done with that one
he started working on this one so he
brought in pretty much like all the jim
henson production team to work on
the plant the audrey ii now
i want to kind of get into because like
i said when we were re-watching this i
haven't seen it a long time and i
remember the plant being really cool but
i had forgotten what a [ __ ] i mean
it is just like a triumph of practical
effects yeah the way that this [ __ ]
play lives on the thing moves and it
just looks like it's alive and what's
great about it is that you can cg can
never give you a product like this never
because it is a character in the movie
and it's obvious that the actors are
looking at it and acting with it and
it's just not the same with cg yeah cg
they're you know they're imagining it
being there the the eye contact really
isn't there it's just it [ __ ] is
great man it's just this is one of the
greatest practical effects i've seen
yeah i think yeah and i don't think
anyone's going to argue with it this is
easily one of the best practices not
just in the 80s but just like of all
time no it's not supposed to look alive
it's alien and it's this is the tone of
this is a musical so it's a fantasy
creature
but it looks like it's alive yeah it
doesn't look
it's difficult when you see it you see
i'm talking the colors are a little more
candy colored you know what i mean it's
not really kind of possible in nature
some of the stuff is obviously plastic
but it's talking you're buying it
it just the way it moves is just like so
fluid and like the way its mouth moves
and stuff yeah so they had like a bunch
of like i said this is mostly the way
they did audrey 2
was
all puppetry uh they had like 60 people
like working if you see some of the back
uh behind the scenes footage which i've
seen like some clips of there's
there's like tons and tons of people
like working cranks and [ __ ] like that
like for all the tentacles and like all
the leaves and like little the little
buds like later on they're talking too
like yeah like at the later things the
backup singers do yeah
so they had like a whole bunch of
different versions because the plant as
you know over the course of the thing is
rick miranda's like keeps feeding it
people it keeps getting bigger and
bigger so they had like six different
ones like six different sizes and
another thing they did too was that you
know uh mushnik's flower shop they had
um i think they built that set three
times like in different sizes so they
could do some shots in like forced
perspective uh to make it look bigger
the thing that i didn't know about this
movie and the more like when i read this
this kind of blew my mind a little bit
so they said um
what what they did was that when they
were first working on the plant and they
were trying to get the plant to you know
sing obviously uh and levi stubs from
the four tops uh does the voice he did
like a lot of voice work for cartoons
and chill later on as well but he just
like really makes this a character it's
just like amazing
and
so they they said we when we first did
the puppet and we did like the kind of
you know we were trying to get it to
sing and everything that like it just
didn't look right and we couldn't figure
out like how to get it to work
and so then they said when we were
watching the dailies and it was going
slower or faster we noticed that when we
like slowed it down or speeded it up it
actually looked more alive
so what they ended up doing this like
[ __ ] blows my mind what they ended up
doing was that when the plant was
talking or singing they would play the
um the song at like uh you know like a
quarter speed or something like that and
then they would slo-mo
and then it would under-crank it yeah
they said which is easy when no humans
were interacting with the plant however
when you had scenes where humans were
interacting with the plant the humans
had to do everything in slow motion so
it would all
line up together it worked
and you would never ever [ __ ] know
that so like so anytime you see like you
know audrey two and rick moranis like
talking to each other
rick moranis is moving and moving and
talking in slow motion because that was
the only way they could get the plant
because then they could speed it up yeah
and you know and then it would look like
the plant was like really talking like
really quickly and stuff like that
because they said they just couldn't get
it right when it was like at the right
speed poor rick just about a month ago
somebody just randomly ran up to him and
just busted him in the mouth and beat
him up did you know that uh-uh i haven't
heard of it i hadn't heard about just a
random attack during the damn [ __ ]
that's going on in new york came out of
his he came out of his apartment
somebody just ran up on him just started
beating on him and then the dude ran off
ain't that something yeah i hadn't heard
about that man that's [ __ ] terrible
that is terrible yeah little bitty
mirandas yeah i mean you know
[ __ ] he's not even one rogan tall
he's like point six rogan's
6.6 rogans in height
yeah yeah
1.2 rogans oh okay yeah
but yeah so so yeah so in case okay so
in case you guys didn't know
like i said the story of this is
basically rick moranis plays uh you know
a kind of a dorky uh flower shop worker
uh you know who
finds a plant it's kind of like a venus
flytrap
and finds out that it uh you know drinks
human blood and it gets bigger and
bigger and like i said the more it gets
bigger like the more famous the shop
gets like you know his boss uh you know
he's giving him raises he's getting
famous uh you know he's trying to get
the girl and everything like that and uh
it's it's interesting because in the
movie
um it's kind of like rick moranis
character uh
whose name is seymour
he's kind of like
he didn't kill like okay so in the
original movie they do have the dentist
and all that other kind of stuff but in
the original movie the dentist isn't
audrey's boyfriend he's just like the
dentist and he's just like a random
[ __ ] that you know that seymour has
to go see the dentist because his tooth
hurts and like the guy's a dick so he
just ends up kind of accidentally on
purpose killing him
um in this one and this is kind of
strange and i had actually forgotten
about this aspect of the 1986 version
where steve martin's character the
dentist um
is actually uh a real abusive uh
boyfriend like beats audrey up like
gives her a black eye breaks her arm
and they almost kind of like
make a few jokes about it like she said
like when he turns up missing she's kind
of like it would be a miracle if he you
know was dead or whatever because like
it would save me all this money and like
epsom salts and ace bandages yeah it's
so [ __ ] up well it's not realism
but i had forgotten forgotten about that
yeah so i got a steve martin character
you know what i mean he's this ultra dom
abusive dom he beat her up for falling
off the motorcycle and [ __ ] it is over
the top yeah
yeah and sadistic you see yes
and like i said the dentist song in this
it's like holy crap i still remember all
the words like this many years later
because like i said i used to have the
soundtrack they're poking fun at the
dental industry
it's as if [ __ ]
it's as if you have to be a saddest to
to be a dentist yeah that's that's the
joke but yeah so so the first thing is
that when he um you know when rick
mourinho's when uh seymour finds out
that audrey ii like needs blood and he's
kind of giving it to his fingers but of
course he can't do that for very long
and so then uh the dentist actually he
goes there to kill the dentist but he
doesn't actually kill the dentist the
dentist kind of like dies because of his
own misadventure
uh but you know but seymour does
actually like cut him up and feed him to
the plant and then he was addicted to
nitrous oxide yeah so he would ride that
was another night he brings nitrous with
him
and he had a special [ __ ] respirator
for nitrous when he was doing work on
certain people he was really getting
into it so he could get high while he
was inflicting pain
great character the antique dental tools
yeah yeah
it's a great it's a great character i
think it's one of i think it's martin's
one of martin's finest roles her finest
performances at least it kind of kind of
really [ __ ] really knocks it out of
the park it kind of reminded me of um
him playing uh the like maxwell in uh
maxwell silverhammer and yeah versus
hart's club it's kind of a similar type
of thing better though but he's way more
over the top i mean just when he comes
in and like just singing the dennis song
and just punches that nurse in the face
and then like pulls that little girl the
dog that little doll head off
performance was so good that i would
suspect he had a
cocaine relapse
because mark was great when he was
cooked up
i mean yeah and i like just watch old as
saturday night live when he was on there
he was [ __ ] coked to the gills he
might have been in this one too because
it is very very it's a very physical
performance like he's like the way he's
like gesturing and stuff it's just like
very it's very very funny he had nerd
rage
but he plays a real cool character who's
[ __ ] really sadistic and [ __ ]
dominant and [ __ ]
and it's it's funny it's like lux
interior very much yeah it's funny
because that actually did occur to me
when i was re-watching it that that is a
very luxe interior-esque type of
character yeah um but yeah so
it's so okay so
as it goes like and rick moranis he
actually so he chops the dentist up and
feeds it to the plant the plant gets
bigger
and then he doesn't like then mr mushnik
his boss like gets eaten too but he
doesn't really
kill him in the sense that you know
because mr mushnik just kind of like
backs into the plant and then the plant
eats him
and so there's kind of this thing where
um you know he wanted to get famous so
he could get audrey but audrey said she
loved him anyway
and um so he figures out that um the
plant actually is from outer space and
actually just wanted to get bigger and
like reproduce and essentially take over
the world so he decides that he has to
destroy it now it does actually try to
eat audrey but
he comes in in the nick of time and
saves her and they have a happy ending
where they go to this uh you know little
suburban home with like stripes on the
lawn and little white picket fence and
[ __ ] like that
now here's the interesting thing though
and i didn't actually know this until
pretty recently because i had always
seen like the theatrical version
you know which came out in 1986 which
it wasn't um
a failure at the theater it made money
but it didn't make as much as they were
expecting
however when it came out on home video
it like was a huge huge hit and uh
subsequently like got a big cult
following so it wasn't like you know
real big at the theater but it really
kind of well greece was like that yeah
it was the same because i kind of feel
like a lot of people maybe don't go see
musicals in the theater or at least they
did it in the 80s
so maybe that's what it was they'd see
them but it wasn't they were never
blockbusters yeah that's a home video
thing yeah but it's good you can sit
there and you can drink you know what i
mean with your girlfriend or whatever
and [ __ ] watch musicals
yeah or you just sit there with your
boyfriend when you watch musicals i
don't know or your with your dog or your
cat or your
because you know the songs well yeah and
especially if it's kind of there's an
element of nostalgia to it you know i
think i think that that they're the most
effective when they're like that yeah i
put up there with grease and xanadu and
[ __ ] you know yeah they're just like
super fun and this one is super fun
because
i mean who doesn't like i'm not a
massive fan of musicals but i really
like
horror musicals um and this one is kind
of like
a horror movie in the sense that it's an
homage to old b movies um and it's also
a black comedy and i love those
now interestingly though as dark as this
movie is as in it's a big giant alien
plant that eats people and you know you
have to cut people up and like feed them
to the plant and [ __ ] like that um and
also the whole domestic abuse thing uh
you know that's dark enough however the
original ending of the off-broadway play
uh was supposed to be the same ending as
the movie
um and i hate to spoil it if you haven't
seen this but at the end of the
off-broadway play
um audrey you know the the love interest
she actually uh you know seymour comes
in and like sees her in the plant's
mouth and pulls her out
in the theatrical version she lives and
they go on and get married and it's they
live happily ever after however in the
off-broadway version and in the original
uh movie version
audrey dies
um and she actually the last thing she
tells him because her wounds are to our
mortal wounds right the last thing she
says to seymour
um after he says yeah i was feeding you
know the people to the plant like so we
could get rich and famous or whatever so
i could you know get you as a girlfriend
and she says well after i die feed me to
the plant
so he feeds her to the plant
and then he's gonna go
kill himself he goes to jump off a
building
and then while he's up there like a guy
comes like a marketing guy comes and
says i'm going to take some cuttings off
that plant and we're going to sell them
all over the world and we'll be rich and
everything and by this point seymour
knows that it's an alien and that's what
it wants it wants to like take over the
whole planet so he says no i can't let
you do that and so he tries to go in
there and fight the plant um but the
plant also eats him so seymour and
audrey both die
the plant
the marketing guy takes cuttings from
the plant sells little audrey twos all
over the country and then those audrey
two start getting bigger and bigger and
take over the whole uh planet like the
triffids yeah yeah so if you go on
youtube and i watched this earlier today
if you go on youtube and put in a little
shop of horrors 1986 original ending you
can see the work print of the last 23
minutes and it makes me really sad
that frank oz and his team they did an
amazing
giant plant rampage at the end of the
thing where the plants are just like
busting out of buildings and there's
like knocking bridges over and it's just
like they're destroying whole cities
and it's so [ __ ] great and it was all
done with like miniatures it looks
amazing
and i was just kind of like so what hap
that's actually how the how the play
ends right
where seymour and audrey both die and
the plants win they take over the planet
because like i said it was supposed to
be like an homage to b movies
so apparently so they shot that ending
and then when they showed the movie to
test audiences test audiences hated it
yeah and i was like back in the 80s back
in the 80s yeah nowadays you could do
that and everybody would just think it
was fantastic but back then everybody's
like no we wanted a happy ending we
liked seymour and audrey we don't want
them to die we don't want the plant to
win so they had to come they had to get
everybody back for reshoots so they
could show him like electrocuting the
plant and like killing the planet
winning and saving uh audrey and
everything like that so it was like this
big pain in the ass and um it's funny
because they asked frank oz about it and
he's like maybe it's because he's like
he's like i don't know why they would
accept that you know that sad ending or
like the tragic ending in the play but
not in the movie
and he said it's a different demographic
yeah and he said yeah that too but he
said maybe it's because like after the
play is over all the actors come out on
the stage and bow and it's like you can
see they're still alive and stuff
whereas like in a movie you don't have
that
but what they did was in back in 2012
they actually found um all the footage
that they had shot for the original uh
ending of the movie and they it was kind
of shitty but they restored it all and
they put it um they released it on
blu-ray like as the director's cut and
then they kind of took it around to
theaters and re-showed in the theaters
and they said they asked frank oz about
that and he said in 2012 he's like i
thought everyone was going to hate the
ending again he's like but now everybody
[ __ ] loves it yeah you know it's like
the [ __ ] plant rampage and like i
said they you know if go watch it
because it's like it looks really great
and it's like it's am i known in that
yeah it kind of bums me out that
you know the the special effects team
did all of that work and they threw it
away and then they didn't even use it
and also there was like a couple of
songs that they cut out too like
like don't feed the plants uh was
supposed to be like the finale song in
the director's cut okay yeah so they're
in there
um yeah so i mean i know they they did
cut out i think five songs
from the original play uh you know into
the movie and then they actually
wrote one the the song uh mean green
mother from outer space uh that he sings
at the end like telling uh seymour he's
an alien audrey too um that was actually
written specifically for the movie and
was actually um nominated for an academy
award for best song that year although
it didn't work the theatrical version
that i saw
today what we're reviewing now i'd
probably put it up there in line with
like grease
but the new one you're talking about the
restored director's cut sounds like i
might put that one up there with like um
like a demon street of was it uh [ __ ]
tweeny sweeties
because that was that was true horror
right there horror musical
yeah dark ending and everything i mean
you i like i said i watched the the you
know the
the original ending like on youtube
um
and if you get the director's cut
they've restored the original ending so
it goes just the way the original movie
would have gone that the test audiences
didn't like back in the 80s and it's
honestly it's like as much as i liked
the characters of seymour and audrey
that would have been sad if they died
and it's kind of cute that they had like
the happy ending and everything i'm kind
of like watching you know the the plant
rampage ending and i'm just like yeah i
kind of think this might be better
um and it's just kind of it's
interesting and a lot of people that i
was watching a lot of reviews of this
and
a lot of reviewers nowadays probably
like younger ones and stuff like that
are kind of like yeah nowadays i don't
think anybody would have a problem with
having an ending like that with like the
protagonist dying and like the plants
just winning and taking over the earth
um but you know i guess back in the 80s
everyone was bummed out by it and didn't
want to see that so
but it's funny because i didn't actually
know that until recently that uh that
that was the original ending and i was
like
i don't know i might have liked that
better but yeah so as i said this movie
even if you don't like musicals because
i know a lot of people don't like
musicals but
even if you don't like musicals you
should totally see this one because
this one is i don't see how you could
not
love this movie this is a delightful
delightful movie to watch it's just like
everything in it it's just like funny it
looks great the entire thing was shot on
a sound stage it was actually pinewood
studios uh in london
you know they built
you can really see like
the love that was put into this like the
artistry of it just this whole like the
whole skid row set with like the train
and everything like that they built all
of that um they built you know the
audrey ii puppet that well they built
several of them because they needed them
at different sizes and if you just watch
that [ __ ] puppet and then look at
like
um you know the behind the scenes stuff
that
kind of detailed how they did that and
how they got it to look the way it looks
like in the movie it's just [ __ ]
unbelievable they just don't they don't
do a lot of practical effects like that
anymore um i mean you know having like
60 people working on this one puppet and
they all had to be like coordinated jim
hansen had a lot to do with it because
he tried to do it after him his son
tried to do it after him and the puppets
never really well now brian henson uh
his son did work on this one too yeah uh
he yeah and um you know so and frank oz
something about that art maybe it was
because uh things became more hd so it
was easier to see flaws i don't know but
i remember the puppetry started to kinda
by the time the 90s and the 2000s that
rolled around had kind of become
kind of inferior
maybe it was just because they didn't
have enough money in it or they didn't
or i don't know if like people didn't go
into i mean look at puppetry anymore
look at yoda in the [ __ ] star wars
prequels it just looked [ __ ] stupid
look like a [ __ ] green rubber [ __ ]
doll
it did look that grogu looks better
looked better than the [ __ ] that than
the the uh the yoda puppet out of
[ __ ]
phantom menace should look like terrible
it did well it's like it i don't know
it's hard to tell because it didn't look
like the original yoda which annoyed me
yeah but it's like you know i so because
like i said frank oz was the puppeteer
on the original yoda from uh
it didn't look real it didn't look alive
the original yoda looked like a living
creature it had eye glass eyeballs like
a real glass eye you know just it just
it looked like a real thing pretty much
most of the time and that's kind of the
same thing about audrey too is that even
though you said it's not realistic in
the sense that it looks like a real
plant
but it looks like a real character yeah
you know what i mean and it looks like
it's talking yeah it totally looks like
it's talking it's moving around like all
of the um you know it's like limbs and
tentacles and stuff that it has like
when it busts out of the pot and like
it's got all this it's just [ __ ] going
across the floor and stuff it's like
it's
i just i was just like watching it last
night even though i've seen the movie a
hundred times but like i said i haven't
seen it in such a long time and just
watching i was just like in awe
at like just the way the mouth moved and
the tongue and like ever like all the
mouth parts are moving everything up
here was moving like all the leaves and
all that kind of stuff and i was just
knowing that there was somebody like you
know under the floor like over here like
just off camera like there's all these
people with like cranks and [ __ ] like
that and servos and whatnot and it's
just like operating that is just
amazing and then when i found out the
[ __ ] about
the plant being under cranked and like
all the actors having to go in slow
motion
you know to
so it would all kind of fit together
when they speeded the film up it's just
i don't know man it's like you don't see
a lot of that kind of artistry
uh that much anymore because yeah i
don't think they care as much
either that or maybe like all the real
talented artistic people are going more
into like digital effects and you don't
get as many people doing because i think
like model makers make yeah back in the
70s 70s and 80s you know you had like
tons of people going into like practical
effects whether it was like you know
going to tom savini school or like you
know jim henson was like kind of a big
deal they were making like labyrinth and
the dark crystal and stuff like that
with like these amazing puppets and like
animatronics and stuff so because you
were seeing that on the screen you had
like younger people coming to school man
like man i want to do that yeah well
then making spaceships all those yeah
spaceships were just they were kit
bashing they would just buy a bunch of
damn model kits and german tanks and
[ __ ] and pieces of flat pieces of
plastic and put all that together and
make a ship you know what i mean and you
know what x-wings and y-wings and
millennium falcons it's just tank parts
and battleship parts and stuff
and it was kind of it was convincing but
but you had to be artistic yeah that was
the british [ __ ] it looked real it
looked like a real cr the italian stuff
from like star crash and [ __ ] you could
tell that they were kit bashing you know
model parts yeah you know you didn't
really that make that much of an effort
yeah you know
only a real genius can make a bunch of
model parts look like
something that came out of a factory
yeah and it's all supposed to be
together
oh i wanted to mention too this when i
was talking about uh you know the
original direct who was supposed to
originally direct this and stuff i can't
honestly i can't imagine like anyone
other than frank oz and like all the
puppeteering and stuff doing that now
you know who they wanted for the role
that um of uh audrey who ellen green
played who actually she uh played that
character in the off-broadway version
which is why they ended up getting her
in the end but they originally wanted um
cindy lopper okay they asked cindy love
what she would have been good too yeah
but um she didn't want to do it uh so
they turned her down but so finally they
got around to and i think they also
asked barbra streisand but barbra
streisand didn't want to do it you have
to think like barbra streisand was much
younger back then yeah she's a bigger
star though too yeah so maybe she's just
like no because this is kind of like a
white snake didn't take it that'd have
been right up her alley she would have
been immortalized in that or maybe she
was i mean i don't know she just didn't
want to do it or if she was like had
some obligation elsewhere like because i
think that happens a lot i don't think
it's so much like oh i don't want to do
that but i've already committed to like
other things
yeah so it's like maybe that was why but
in the end i'm kind of really glad that
they got ellen green to do it to like
reprise her role from the uh from the
stage play because she's like really
good it's like i know that a lot of
people and i kind of had this too when i
was younger like the way that she talks
in this movie like with that little
squeaky voice that she has um some
people think that's like really annoying
but honestly the older i got like when i
watched it last night i just thought it
was like kind of cute and like endearing
you know what i mean that's what it's
supposed to be yeah and have people that
talk like that yeah and because it's
supposed to be set you know in the early
60s yeah it was supposed to be like all
kind of doo-wop and that kind of stuff
so it really kind of fit in with that uh
with that kind of it was supposed to be
like the teeny bopper voice yeah but new
york and she had
big hair like yeah her little like every
time somebody said something exciting
she'd go
you know what i mean it was just like so
[ __ ] funny and she had like this
crazy like [ __ ] pumps and all that
other stuff and i also want to say too
that um i really liked the uh the greek
chorus in this like the the three girls
yeah crystal ronnette and chiffon were
their names uh named after some girl
groups from that era yeah so uh so yeah
if you haven't seen it it's on we rented
it on amazon prime it's 3.99 uh if you
want to see the original which actually
i'm kind of glad i watched it even
though the original is not a musical
um you know but the story is kind of the
same um it's you know it's got some
differences and it's obviously like
super super cheap but the original is
actually a pretty decent watch too and
it's actually like way funnier than i
was expecting it to be i guess um but
that's on amazon prime or not yeah it's
on amazon prime with ads and it's also
on 2b with ads so you can watch that one
for free but uh yeah if you haven't seen
little shop of horrors totally watch it
the theatrical version the one with the
happy ending
is the one that's on
amazon prime i think if you want the
director's cut
you probably have to get the blu-ray
like the one with the plant rampage at
the end like where where everybody dies
um but
i've seen i haven't seen like the whole
movie like put together but i did we
watched the theatrical cut last night
and then i watched the um just the last
23 minutes
you know with the with the plant rampage
and it's like so i don't know i kind of
feel like maybe we should get the
blu-ray that has that version on it yeah
because that might be like super cool
and like i said i'm kind of bummed that
that uh that that last song got taken
out the finale song but oh well what are
you gonna do but yeah seriously if you
haven't seen this even if you don't like
musicals um i would still recommend
watching this because it's super super
fun and it's just
i mean just watch it for that [ __ ]
plant alone and for the for the dentist
scene like with steve martin and bill
murray because that is [ __ ] comedy
steals the show it kind of does yeah and
i feel like i mean i think that when you
when you search this movie on youtube um
you know
videos of that scene kind of like
overwhelm the rest of this stuff he does
some [ __ ] motorcycle impossibility
he's got this full dressed harley and
he's all [ __ ] rigged up in his den
bondage dennis outfit mixed with
motorcycle stuff
comes [ __ ] pulling up to his office
jumps off the bike while the bike is
still rolling points at the bike and it
stops
an impossibility of course
the brakes don't work that way it's just
and then the bike doesn't even fall over
so funny bike doesn't even fall over
you're like
full command over everything that's how
dumb he is
[ __ ] right i mean just oh my god just
the whole [ __ ] thing and i had
forgotten i mean like i remembered the
song and everything but i had forgotten
how [ __ ] funny that [ __ ] scene was
like which oh my god but yeah seriously
if you haven't seen it a long time go
watch it watch it for the dennis scene
watch it for that [ __ ] plant because
it's amazing all the songs are amazing
it's just like a really really fun
it's a really fun [ __ ] time you know
so go watch it all right so that'll do
it for this movie respective and we will
see you guys on the next one
bye